The average percentage of obese people in all states is 27%.
With the help of some interactivity on this graphic,
I can hover over this black middle line and see that.
Here's the figure.
For the second question, we were looking for DC, or the District of Columbia.
This question was a bit easier to answer.
We can determine these rankings by looking at the state that's on
the left side here.
So if I just hover over,
this would be the least educated state by population, West Virginia.
The most educated would be up here, the District of Columbia.
And finally, most states have higher percentages of obese people.
This one is harder to notice from the graph, but
it's recognizable from the color of the lines.
Looking at our plot,
we can tell that slightly more lines are red rather than blue.
So, slightly more states have larger pair of percentages of obese people,
compared to percentages of people with higher educations.